we're babies in the business industry
we're babies in content just starting to
try we got like 250 followers on
Instagram but we better than zero better
than zero exactly so we're starting to
throw it I would just ask maybe what
would be some advice that you have for
someone who's just starting off you need
to start googling and youtubing and
podcasting and educate yourself on
something I call sock strategic organic
content not just posting happy [__]
Wednesday and hoping it works like why
are you posting I need you to understand
the thumbnail the first 3 seconds what
time you po post how many words which
platform what's going on in LinkedIn
carousels that's different than Facebook
carousels Facebook reals What are
broadcast channels my social media
strategy is not the
following attention is the number one
asset super excited to be here
um look anytime I'm in Jersey uh it
always feels like home I uh I was born
in the Soviet Union uh but came to
America when I was three and and uh and
first lived in Queens but a couple years
in we moved to do I lived there for a
year and then uh and then I moved to
Edison New Jersey in
1982 and that's really where my life
began my entrepreneurial career my
football fandom uh I really wish Eric
Godfrey who was the kid I met outside
throwing a football said to me that he
was a Giants fan cuz I'd have four Super
Bowls unfortunately he said he was a
Jets fan I have none um but uh um look
it's really exciting to be here I mean I
think it you know when I do something
like this I think about how do I bring
the most value and so I'd love to do a
ton of Q&A um because I think that's how
I can bring the most value to this
audience I think that before I get into
that just to do some kickoff remarks and
things of that nature I really do think
the world of business and really life at
some level because I ironically what I'm
about to talk about I think really
bleeds into P parenting and other things
I think the world is very very much in a
place where the two C's have my
attention which is
culture uh and content you know so how
many people here are business owners
raise your hands um I know some of you I
recognize some faces um you know I I
don't think most business owners really
actually walk the walk on company
culture and I'm empathetic like if you
go out of business there is no company
so I get the concept of having to make
tough decisions and firing people or you
know being stressed but I I really
believe that for the far majority of the
people that just rais their hand who own
businesses if you over index both on
giving a [__] about your employees like
actually you know which also means like
telling something I struggled with most
of my career telling them the truth when
they're not performing instead of just
firing them randomly at a left field um
if you really focus on culture and
understand that retention of your
employees always grows your business
there's a lot of costs involved in
retraining someone I know you know that
as a matter of fact a lot of you know it
so well that you're actually holding on
to some people that do need to go cuz
you know how hard it is to retrain what
that person knows for seven years so
it's a fine balance but then the thing
that clearly led to me being able to sit
in front of all of you here today
content you know obvious I built a very
large liquor store in Springfield New
Jersey for my dad with Wine Library that
hopefully some of you have driven by or
even stopped into and at first it was
because I was just good at retail in the
same way that I was good at selling OJ's
rookie cards at a baseball card show
Once I learned cuz I knew Sports once I
learned wine I was good at selling all
of you wine and I thought I was a
Salesman as I got older and I started
working my dad's store when I was 14
years old stocking shelves every
vacation every weekend every summer day
and so by the time I was 22 and running
the store full-time I was an OG I had
eight years of real work not like the
way kids work today and so I thought as
myself as a Salesman but in hindsight as
I get to sit here today and I'm like
what can I say that will make them do
something that will make it good for
them the two things I bet on in my
career and everything I've built is
innovation and content so innovation
is me launching a website in 1997 for my
dad's one store liquor store in
Springfield mberg people literally told
my dad that like I was going to ruin his
business not because they were mad at me
because they loved my dad they they saw
him go from a stock boy who couldn't
speak English to owning this store and
they've known him for 20 years and here
I was coming along and spending $10,000
which was a lot of money for a small
business in 1997 to build a website
everybody told me kid you don't get it
this is the liquor business nobody's
going to buy wine on the
internet for the youngsters in here
there's plenty of ogs and Grays hairs in
here so you'll get it but for the
youngsters in here a lot of people
thought the internet was a fat a lot of
people and so people were like open a
second liquor store not this internet
thing and then instead of doing
cataloges or running full page ads in
the Star Ledger which I did
but instead of that I started to send
emails in 1997 with wine offering it
wasn't I wasn't a rocket scientist
cataloges and the Star Ledger were
expensive email was free but in 1997
9899 2000 and all of you will remember
this if you live through that era we
were reading like every email we weren't
getting spammed like we are now how many
people here have done email marketing
close enough to like know it a little
bit in your careers raise your hand
perfect in 1998 I had 100,000 people on
an email newsletter with 87% open
rates now if you're at 30% you're a
genius but that was because it was new
but it wasn't too new that it wasn't
real the metaverse is coming it's real
that's going to impact your business
events are going to be in a metaverse
that will happen but 18 years from today
and so you get to decide like how much
that matters to you what are your
ambitions retired so you're like [__]
that [__] I don't
care but but for a lot of youngsters in
here like if you know that's going to
change the game people back to work from
home trust me I have 2,000 Global
employees I don't think anyone's working
uh you know um but like man work from
home like Jesus like the advancements of
the metaverse we are going to like think
about what Zoom meetings feel like now
all of us know that you can you can be
productive we taught us ourselves that
during Co when we go into the metaverse
and you're getting the things that you
lose in Zoom like really when it's there
in 15 years and it actually feels like
you're in the room you know not like a
video game but like actually like that
will change the way we work so I've
always believed in Innovation the thing
is I don't want to get too far ahead of
it so for instance I recently helped my
dad's uh liquor store I innovated a
luckily six months before covid and I
created something called winetext.com
for him you get a text every day like
old group on some crazy deal like
yesterday was a $130 Napa Valley Cab for
40 bucks because we look at 10,000 wines
a year to find 365 good ones we're
getting crazy deals but it's better it's
like old email when you get a text and
all you have to do is reply with how
many bottles you want and it's sent to
your home that's good shopping
eliminating friction making it more
convenient every single business in here
if they make it more convenient for
someone to buy will grow their business
we spend money on time all the time
there are people here who've ordered a
$5 Burger on Postmates but it cost you
$29 to get it delivered but the time was
worth it for you at this point in your
life time is always a value play so
Innovation especially when it gives back
the cons consumer time when everybody
was making fun of me in ' 9798 99 that
nobody would buy I remember one guy very
successful guy was pushing me hard
trying to prove his point and he ended
with like Gary how many people do you
really
think in 10 years are going to buy wine
on the
internet and my answer was
everyone and not that I believed
everyone but I believed a lot and I
think many people here know that if you
really take yourself back to what you
thought you would do versus what you're
actually doing technology always wins
there's plenty of people here who did
not want to get an iPhone because they
love their Blackberry cuz they could
touch the
buttons nobody here is rocking a [__]
blackberry and so one thing to always
think about is innovation but not so far
out that it's not practical this is not
the time to go all in and bet your
company on the metaverse but keep a
little eye on it because could be wrong
about 12 years apple or Facebook or
Netflix or BMW or Google could launch
something tomorrow and everything speeds
up this phone the iPhone was invented
and everything changed the next
day right if you think about the biggest
companies in the world the Facebooks and
the Ubers and right they don't exist if
there wasn't a platform called the
mobile device that has the internet on
it so that's Innovation content is
probably the thing that I most want to
leave here inspiring people here to do
whether you're a lawyer an accountant in
the service business if you're a VP of
sales if you don't even have your own
business I know as I look at all these
faces that everybody including myself
someone who puts out 50 pieces of
content a day across YouTube Facebook
Instagram Snapchat Tik Tok LinkedIn
every person in this room right now
including me does not post enough on
social media if they want to grow their
business and I know most of you don't
post at all
and so there is this
shocking reality right now in the world
where people continue to disrespect
social media as a driver to what they
want whether that is growing your
business whether that is running for
local office whether that is raising
money for your local charity or
something you care about the attention
of the world is my currency it's the
only thing I care about
you can't get anything done unless you
have somebody's
attention since I was seven on tingly
Lane in Edison New Jersey and would walk
that street to figure out where I should
put my lemonade sign to get more people
to buy my lemonade to sitting today and
looking at everything that's happening
on streaming services and social
networks for the last 40 years all I've
paid attention to is where's the
attention whether that's Direct Mail
Star Ledger New York Times Google
Facebook Tik Tok influencers athletes
sport where's the
attention everybody here needs to make a
much bigger commitment to understanding
where the attention is not where your
attention is if I hear one more business
owner or executive say well Gary I don't
use Tik Tok I go no [__]
Don but your customer does making
decisions for your business based on
your personal opinion
of what people should be doing with
their time is one of the stupidest
business strategies of all time you
should be 100%
agnostic on where you spend your time
and money you should care where your
customers are not where you think they
should be that is a massive mistake I
see every day so look I think I think
the world continues to evolved I don't
have to tell everybody in this room
there's a lot going on yesterday was the
election it means the 20 24 election
season has begun right so it's going to
be plenty of feelings and all sorts of
stuff going on and it is all playing out
on your phone the phone has become the
television and the television has become
the
radio got it Joe that's what's happened
if you want a history lesson go look
what happened in the 50s and 60s in
America how all the biggest businesses
in the world lost market share and how
all the current businesses that are the
biggest businesses in the world right
now started to grow and and the one
variable was the following some people
held on to running ads on radio and
others jumped into
television do you know that Amazon was
the biggest spender on Google AdWords
the first 5 years of Google AdWords by a
10x multiplier there's a direct reason
why Amazon's one of the biggest
companies in the world they understood
where to spend the money on the
underpriced
attention so that's kind of where I want
to lead the Q&A to like really help you
one by one are you guys gonna run mics
for Q&A yeah I think we have we do look
I I'll jump on culture while I get the
team set up for mics but thank you it's
not going to work it's always crasp
me um what I what I the other thing I
want to talk about is culture real quick
I just want to make this point because I
think a lot of people in this room might
be struggling with this I I genuinely do
not believe gen Z is
lazy I I I really don't I think that a
lot lot of us are spending too much time
demonizing the upand cominging
generation about being lazy and entitled
I just need you to hear this for me of
look I know unlimited people that are
lazy in the Boomer and Gen X and
Millennial set too and entitled it's not
that they're lazy and entitled it's that
they have
options they don't want to work for you
for $18 an hour doing dumb [__] when
they can just post silly videos on Tik
Tok and make $38 an
hour
so I'm saying this because I want to
leave here with y'all winning after I
leave some of you might be I need to
actually be nicer to my employees real
talk some of you it might be yeah it's
2024 and everything that's happening in
the world is based on social media
content it might be a good idea for me
to finally take this serious for
business for some of you it might be you
stop complaining about these kids don't
want to work and realize
why it's because they have options the
average 18-year-old kid knows that they
can make $50,000 a year on the internet
for them pretty
easily and so we have to understand that
we have to adjust and once you
understand that truth and don't just
spend your time dwelling or shooting the
[__] with your other person that's mad
about it and you start attacking of what
you're going to do about it to grow your
business you become accountable to truth
instead of trading on
ideology so those are the themes that's
what I'd love to talk about I'm really
appreciative of everybody being here so
thank you for having
[Applause]
me now I know there's a lot of people
here that I've you know interacted with
in the past or know my stuff or have
just met me like I I'm here to I'm here
to bring value so be selfish on this Q&A
ask me whatever you want make it very
narrow it doesn't have to touch on
anything I just talked about I'm here
for overall business Q&A so who
wants should I wait for a mic yeah let's
wait for the mics so everybody can hear
the questions what's your name brother
uh my name is Kevin Kevin um I work for
a Pharma company um and we kind of
developed a unique uh concept of merging
Pharma with franchising yep um it's one
of a kind nobody's doing that in the US
um however there is still the
opportunity as you just mentioned about
attention where is being attention it's
the Internet it's the digital world so
in your sense you are the franchise or
and you have a and you're looking for
franchises okay keep going so the idea
is that we still have a lot of people
lot of business owners and CEO who have
that old scho mentality where they don't
want to spend too much time and money on
the internet and digital scen uh how do
you still like try to convince them or I
guess Coe and Cote scare them into
thinking that hey if you don't spend the
money there you're not going to get the
customers and even without doing that
we've been able to do it because I had a
marketing and business development for
it uh however I I do feel like just you
said like attention is right there the
customers right there but we are not
spending too much time and money in your
model you're getting a certain
percentage from them for marketing do
they have to kick you three like most
franchise or do the franchisees have to
give you 3 to 5% for your marketing
budget so we we try to keep it simple
where anything you sell you get 40% of
business uh just again because the fact
that whole business of look I got it
look I and listen I run a agency and I'm
going to give you my best piece of
advice on this and it's a challenging
piece of advice in the seat that you're
sitting but I think when we talk it
through for a minute here you'll
understand why cuz you cuz you're going
to know it's true my friends the number
one issue in the world politics religion
uh business is everyone's in the
business of
convincing everyone's spending all their
time trying to convince everyone else to
see it the way they see it whatever it
is so to your point you're trying to
convince these franch es to do the right
thing to grow their business the problem
is it is very hard to
convince so in our organization and
everything I do for a living as a
businessman I say don't convince have
conviction so instead of spending even
one minute trying to convince someone
that you already know the second you
start talking to them you know you're
like [__] this isn't happening spend all
your time on you marketing what you
control to create the case studies for
them I've I've innovated my whole career
when I sell new stuff I do that all the
time I don't even spend a s another
minute with 98% of the people I talk to
or Market to because I know there is no
convincing I just look for the 2% that
understand what the hell I'm talking
about build and then let the C everybody
made fun of me about the internet until
they didn't everybody made fun of me for
doing a wine show on YouTube in 20 06
here in Jersey until they did it
everybody made fun of me for taking my
life savings and investing in a company
called the Facebook Twitter and Tumblr
until they didn't they laugh at you and
then your competitors cry and so I think
you have to be in the conviction
business I don't think you will convince
them I think you have to do good
marketing show them the Raz the ROI the
CAC the LTB of the marketing you do and
then just keep feeding them the
information of like you're leaving money
on the table and the case studies will
always do the work better than you just
talking it thanks man big of thank you
brother yeah let's clap it up for him
solid
question who's got the
mic yeah let's double up the mics good
idea oh
hi s what's your name hi everyone um my
name is ly and I um actually I just
completed seven years of business on
Saturday I have a production company
events agency where we specialize in
food and music festivals and we just
started a friend over here from Atlanta
we just started going into Atlanta love
it um I saw you at the event expoo the
92nd 2019 oh in 19 I did it the other
day on the 92nd 92nd Street why yeah
iing no right
respect and uh so at that talk you were
spending time you got a lot of
conviction about Tik Tok yes and 2019
everyone it was it just you know wasn't
musically anymore and it was still you
know the dances and the lip sinking and
no one took it seriously and you had
said something that really stuck out
which was be where the young kids are
where the twin are because then
eventually their older siblings get on
that parents get on Facebook was for
college kids now it's for grandmas these
things age up it's how they work go
ahead so I took that and that day I
downloaded Tik Tok and I started messing
around with it and it's very adding as
many of us probably know now and I kind
of just understood the language of it
which is another thing we talk about the
language of the platform slang matters
yep and just or even just the way to
communicate authenticity of it and then
the pandemic H and I had already been
established on Tik Tok at that point
with my business and we do food
festivals you make fun content I'm
promoting local restaurants so that when
I'm doing something with food you
already trust me yep and now my business
has really grown we have I mean 65,000
compared people is a lot but for a
festival lot for a Bea be event business
65,000 is INS Tik and then Tik Tok ads
came out yes and I found that it wasn't
wasn't killing it on Tik Tok ads and I
don't know if I don't necessarily
understand the ads or the algorith was
weird and then this year Instagram
actually started being like Instagram
reals started being more lucrative for
me and also you need put $10 a day and
it's just going crazy so now my
Instagram is doing really well we have
35,000 I have one specifically for our
Atlanta events that went is even higher
than my jersey and I've been doing
Jersey for seven years and so I'm
wondering my question G with all that
being said is where do you think the
next platform is and do you think Tik
Tok advertising is up they figured it
out couple things there
so every one of these platforms so I
love when people like Gary like
inevitably one of you may email me or
send me a message after this talk and be
like hey heard you but like I did Tik
Tok for 6 months and it didn't work and
I'm like cool I played football in my
backyard it didn't work out the same way
it did for
OJ like the ROI of a basketball for
LeBron James is going to end up being
billion ions of dollars for me like
negative 20,000 I have two torn
meniscuses so to your point you figured
out organic Tik Tok and you were good at
it to your credit Tik Tok ads are not as
strong converters as Instagram and
Facebook cuz meta has been around for 15
years and has refined it do I believe
that Tik Tok ads work yes do I believe
that's reserved currently for the best
1% of operators on it yes even us who
are the crew like it es and flows as we
refine our capability on it and the
platform does Instagram ads work
remarkable because meta's data on their
consumer is
bananas Tik tok's algorithm is addicting
because it gives you what you want to
look at but it doesn't understand you as
well it understands what you like but
Facebook like really knows what you buy
like got it so like you could like some
you could love the Jets or the Giants
but you might not be someone who buys
football jerseys
whereas someone else might like it half
as much but buys 10 a year Facebook's
better at understanding that than Tik
Tok hence why converting is different
right but that abs and flows and Tik Tok
will get there um as far as the next one
the reason I have a good reputation is I
don't guess when I told you at that
event in 2019 that Tik Tok was next is
because it was Tik Tok was already a
it I'm good at knowing what is it when
the world has hasn't figured it out yet
I'm just a little faster it's like
sports people would not people that
don't really understand Sports even like
a good fan doesn't understand just a
little more speed can change everything
that's why they run in Indianapolis at
the combine those point to might
actually matter especially when it's
later on the game or this that and the
other thing so same with what I do for a
living I don't need to predict anything
I'm just spending every day watching
everything and when it's time when I
know it crossed over over it's not a fat
it's not be real or peach or you know
Vine was on its way Vine was the app
that really was the precursor to
everything we're seeing now but it got
bought by Twitter so it never got to go
like I'm watching everything but the
second I know I get I'm I'm very
intellectually generous the second I
know it's there I tell the world because
nobody's going to it's not like some
weird secret that you're going to take
for me there's so much for all of us
even today the people that are sitting
here which is I know the majority that
have not gone all in on content on
social networks they may be sitting here
feeling like it's too late what's cool
about social media marketing is it's a
game of better not a game of first I
need a lot of you to hear that because I
feel a lot of you are not jumping in
because like [__] I missed that train
it's a game of better it's a game of
better like I was on I was doing Tik Tok
and musically four years before you
heard me say that you know and you
jumped in and did just fine so I don't
know what's next but I spend 24 hours a
day paying attention to make sure I do
know what's
[Applause]
next what's your take on what's your
name my friend uh Samuel Samuel nice to
meet you nice to meet you what's your
take on AI and how that could tie into
uh nfts and if nfts is really still
something after uh the crypto yeah so
there's a lot there so couple things
let's jump on the second part first
nfts the way all of you know them if you
know them now is highly speculative
digital Collectibles similar to the way
internet
stocks back to why I won the internet a
good thing happened to me a I believed
in it and then in 2000 April of 2000 all
the internet stocks crashed and all the
mainstream media said the internet's a
fat what they didn't understand was
greed kicked in people valued pets.com
and all these internet companies like a
billion dollars on Wall Street before
they were
mature so they got lost in the micro not
the macro Beanie Babies are not worth a
fortune but do you know me squish mellow
sold last year stuffed animals are good
got it people don't get it it's macro
micro nfts first of all nfts are much
broader than just digital Collectibles
and art everybody's contracts
in the next decade will be an nft a
non-f fungible token sitting on the
blockchain cuz it will be verified and
non- manipulatable and it's better to
have your house deed there or your car
insurance or your license like
everything will be on the blockchain
it's actually going to become a
profoundly big conversation how many
people here by show of hands don't raise
your hand if you don't know I actually
want to get a sense how many people in
this room know what a deep fake video is
raise your hand great so about 30% so
I'll go into that in a minute but to
give you the previous you it's some
crazy
[__] the blockchain is going to be the
solve for one of the biggest issues in
the world which is deep fake videos so
anyway where do I think nfts are I think
they're exactly where
internet was in April of 2000 everyone
here is like ah that was a fad it was a
scam it was garbage it's one of the
biggest Technologies in the world two
years ago everyone got too caught up in
the collectible part and just like
sneakers and just like trading cards and
just like art the best 1% of digital
Collectibles will be something worth
collecting and 99% won't but people
don't understand that they just look at
the macro right stif bears from Germany
from the 30s and 40s are very expensive
stuffed animals beanie babies aren't so
nfts are macro what vs VF series 1 nfts
if I do the right thing over the next 40
years and we build a Marvel Pokemon
Sesame Street just like like people want
to buy the first comic book of Batman or
the rookie card of Michael Jordan people
will want it cuz the world's going
digital we're not going
back ai ai is one of the biggest
technology that have ever been invented
in the history of
mankind it's not taking your job and AI
robots are not killing your children yet
and so we're good but people are
demonizing AI because we always demonize
new technology ology when the tractor
trailer was invented most of the
Articles written in newspapers about it
were negative cuz it was going to take
people out of jobs cuz almost everybody
worked on
farms what it did was it gave us more
time to do bigger jobs AI is going to
advance everyone's life here let alone
business just like a search engine is
better than going to the dictionary or
the Yellow
Pages like there's a how many people
here in their life went to the Yellow
Pages to look up something raise your
hand everybody who just raised their
hand do we agree it's better to look it
up on our
phone that's AI right now we're
emotional about it job cuz fear we don't
know it what does it mean to me but AI
is going to advance and do things for us
you know how nice it's going to be to
walk into your home say hey Alexa I have
four buddies coming over one's lactose
intolerant two really like spicy food my
one friend really loves like sour beer
one of one of us is really about seafood
can you just order the best combo of
meal at the lowest cost and send it to
my home that's how you're going to order
food in two
years that's a lot better than opening
up Seamless looking at like and seamless
is a lot better than finding a menu in
your drawer and calling the restaurant
like think AI is going to make it is
going to eliminate mundane things and
make them faster so you have more time
to spend with your family think innovate
so I'm very excited about AI do I
believe there's some dangers of course I
do like of course there's things that
will happen but that's everything when
the knife was invented danger came along
with that no really like I I don't think
people use history to understand the
future so that that's kind of how I see
that I'm going to just jump on deep fake
because I want all of you who didn't
raise your hand which is the majority of
this room I would like you to Google it
when you get home deep fake videos are
videos where the AI makes the person say
things that they didn't
say as a public figure I believe within
the next 5 years there will be more
videos of me on the internet where I'm
saying derogatory things using slurs
that are inappropriate making opinions
of future apps that I don't believe and
that within 10 years and remember this
is very powerful over the last 100 years
the judge and the jury of our world has
been video proof video not the Supreme
Court not presidents not religious
leaders video is the judge and jury of
our society we have lived that way for
100 plus years we are about to go into
an era where it will be the opposite
every person in here in 10 years will
not believe a single video they see on
the
internet now what does that mean it
means that most people don't know what
an nft actually is most people don't
know what blockchain is most people
don't understand
cryptocurrency the internet is on
servers I think we all know that but
those servers are controlled by
companies people organizations the
blockchain is decentralized computers
talking to each other meaning nobody
controls it nobody can touch
it so when you put something on there
and mint it like an nft I can sell you a
fake Michael Jordan rookie card I can
sell you a fake pair of Jordans I can
sell you a fake piece of art nobody will
ever sell a nft that is fake cuz you
can't manipulate
it I believe that my content and every
company in the world and every person in
10 years will first upload their video
to the blockchain and then to the
internet and that there will be a system
that allows us to know if I actually
uploaded it and at what time and when
and that will become the checks and
balances I believe the blockchain is
about to become one of the most
important Technologies in the world
today everyone's just griev and
cryptocurrency and Clinton it's it's my
just like by the way a lot of Jesus room
when the internet first came out we were
all taught that it was just information
the information Super Highway instead of
going to library we'd go there it's
obviously evolved into a lot more and
that's how we see that playing
[Applause]
out blue blue hey Master nice to meet
you brother likewise hey so you've been
talk talking a lot about digital you
know the the new age why did you feel it
was so important to uh to exhibit at a
live of that cuz it's real life cuz it's
real life yeah because I think people
want to go like or and I'm about and
right people are like oh you got to be
all digital I'm like we live in real
life right um books when you in he's a
five time New York man the amount of I
have a new book coming out next year
every time I promote it I'll Pro my
birthday's next week think yeah next
week I'll start promoting on my birthday
saying it's coming out next year I will
get 500 comments in Social being like yo
digital boy why are you writing a book
and and sometimes if I'm on in a mood
long flight I'll jump in and reply to
all of them and reply cuz people read
them I'm not I'm not emotional about
digital I actually would be fine if
there was no digital I lived my whole
life and grew up and went through high
school without ever owning a the
computer being on the internet I know
what it tastes like I was cool I liked
it so the reason I believe in events is
when I'm at ComicCon with this booth or
when I'm at the national people are
affected by it people get to experience
my characters they get to take a selfie
with all of them in the background
because the real world exists my problem
is most people in business are over
emotional about either the old world or
the digital world I don't give a [__] I
just want to grow I don't think I get to
decide what most people don't realize is
all of their opinions are based on their
pocket they don't want the digital world
to keep growing because they're not
comfortable with it and they're in the
analog world most digital people don't
understand the value of the real world
cuz they're 100% digital and don't
understand the real world I think you
need to understand
both thank
[Applause]
you plus by the way brother I think they
work together now the reason I believe
in event marketing crazy but I think if
you're going to do an event you need to
film the whole [__] thing and chop up
all the content and post it in
Social I'm doing events for the content
for social my speaking
career Dustin where you at there he is
like of course I want to build this
relationship we're bis debing but part
of the factor of me saying yes to this
cuz it's a lot more valuable for me to
have just paid and not like right like
my time is valuable I can make it work
because he's filming this whole thing
and one of my answers in the Q&A might
be the clip that gets me 2 million views
on LinkedIn and now it's worth it I
speak publicly though I get a good
handsome fee to speak I still
predominantly speak publicly at this
point in my life where my time has
become very valuable for the
content I I do podcasts predominantly to
put on upand cominging podcasters cuz I
know if I do it that will set them off
and I want to give back to upand comers
but also cuz I need the content
bless
you so I think people should be doing
more event marketing not because I'm
trying to be nice to you guys because I
actually believe it and I think but I
think when they're building out their
exhibits or their activation they should
be thinking about the post- production
of the filming for their
social so you're almost executing the
entire concept and strategy of your
experiential for the visual effects of
what will work on these platforms your
reverse engineering the content
distribution not what you think will
work as a sampling Booth you're like
okay wait a minute why don't I put a big
penguin here because or like you know
we've all seen it these restaurants that
make the restaurants built to look
beautiful with all the rose pedals in
the background so all the influencers
take selfies in the back for exposure
you're actually making the real world
built to entice people to create content
to them distribute to the world to build
awareness they're thinking about
building an exhibit they should call
Metro you said Metro
you should definitely call Metro and if
you you and when you call Metro if you
use the code Gary ve it's 90%
[Applause]
off Michael yes hi Gary how are you very
well first and foremost thank you for
shaking my hand before before you I've
been following me since my high college
professor showed me here I haven't
turned back thank you brother so I'm in
the business man I had the business
education I started my own DJing
business uh so I do that as a passion
project but on my normal 9 to5 I just
recently within the past 3 weeks went
from a Salesman to inside sales manager
company selling liquid level Gates and
slight flow indicators um for liquid
application seeing things through pipes
or levels on a boiler right the cool
[__] yeah cool stuff um so my question
is we just got bought out by a bigger
company we went from a small Mom Pop
company to a company with 300 plus
employees we went from a company with 20
employees to 320 employ different ball
game yep different ball game people are
used to how things run and operate not
only because of the fact that they've
been working there for some of them
their entire career given the owners of
the company and that was bought but then
they we have the sales team myself
included who was used to doing things a
certain way and now it's not only being
done but now I have the authority to
make changes to be to help grow and
increase the business business and make
that positive change for everybody okay
and to also help create a better work
environment and a better culture that
might have lacked prior interesting okay
so when it comes to making all these
changes in time of course of course
during this transitional period how do
you encourage people to embrace the
positiv growth strategies that I want to
impl and make people have confidence in
what you're doing and then not be so
distraught about doing things the way
they were because you're not the owner
of the 300 person company you have to
approach this from a very specific angle
the quickest way to lose trust is not
delivering on your
word so if you start telling all of us
if we're your intire team and you're
like guys it's going to be great and
it's not going to be as challenging or
toxic and everything's rainbows and
shunshine and our Tech stack is
remarkable compared to this and if any
of those don't deliver which you have no
control over
you're dead so the mistake a youngster
like you makes in this world in this
kind of example is you're optimistic
you're hungry you're hopeful but you
have to be incredibly thoughtful of how
you talk to your team you have to talk
to them in what we call in vainer World
Eyes Wide
Open what that means is you need to talk
to them in truth you need to say Hey
listen we know what was wrong in the
last thing we were in we don't know if
it's going to get any better here in
this world world but at least we know
what that was I'm excited over the next
6 months to figure out what this new
leadership is going to do I'm not going
to [__] you Joey Chris Heather I'm
going to speak my truth to anyone who's
willing to listen above me but I'm going
to keep it real with y'all like they're
going to feed me and I'm going to try to
dissect what's real and what's not real
I may be wrong at times but I promise
you my intent for you is good to the
best of my ability the mistake that
people play is they play herob ball when
they don't have
control you have no
control you have some control but the
only person that has control in a
business is the CEO or owner and even in
bigger companies the CEO's really scared
of the board so they don't even have
full control so I I think you need to
tread lightly on your promises speak to
your
intent and massively overc communicate
the biggest thing in my Chris Joe
Heather talk would be like you have my
number or here's my number if you go
home at 7:30 next Thursday I'm pissed
because someone from the new company
pissed you off text me talk to me you
need to build an actual relationship
with them but do not overpromise that is
the killer that everybody walks into in
this
scenario so historically I've been
always taught to one focus on the macro
not the micro something you already
touched on but also I've been taught
historically from various mentors to
resort to
action how would that play a role like
this I think what I just described is
the ultimate action the action is the
real
conversation got it got
[Applause]
pleasure
Joe how are you Joe good
um you know one of the more fulfilling
things that I've experienced through the
years is when
we make a mistake by trying and Learn
and Grow from it it's the best and one
of the most frustrating things I've
experienced in business in life
is failing the same way multiple times
in a row yep until you finally get it
yep I'm just curious for you in in your
career what was a moment where you
taught yourself in that situation
great to your point brother I think a
real entrepreneur fails 98% of the time
I mean I mean I can't even I I could
spend the rest of my life sitting in
front of y'all telling you everything
that hasn't worked out the way I thought
it is because it happens every day to
your point the real [__] is which one
are you doing that's consistently a
problem the glaring most obvious one
because early on I figured out I got
very lucky that I that the internet came
along at the time it that it did and I
was where I was at I would have been a
person that would have guessed about the
next big thing in my early 20s because I
hadn't calibrated yet how long it takes
for Innovation to happen notice how I
said the metaverse is 14 years away at
22 when when I launched wine library.com
in 97 I remember vividly saying to my
friends in college cuz I wasn't out of
college yet I'm like by the year 2000
everybody's going to buy wine on the
internet I didn't realize cuz I'm such a
yes person I didn't realize all of you
are no
people so I knew that that was that I
needed to learn timing but I learned
that one pretty quick I made that timing
mistake wrong a couple times I remember
I bought an ad on luxury.com I'll try to
get louder I bought an ad on luxury.com
in 1998 for like 10,000 bucks a lot of
money and I was like this is going to be
huge like I couldn't wait I mean I
barely Christmas morning stuff I barely
slept the night before cuz I knew it was
going live 9:00 a.m.
Pacific time because they were a cal
Silicon Valley company so noon Jersey
time have my morning and I sat in front
of the
computer at 12:05 to see the orders
coming in and nothing happened I'm like
okay you know 9:00 a.m. and about an
hour in I'm like nothing another hour
nothing I called them I'm like hey do
you have like cuz I could see they had
the right link I'm like am I you know it
was really early internet like we were
all figuring it out and I realized I
bought an ad on what seemed to be a big
site but it didn't have it like I I had
to learn so I learned being too early
but the one that I'm still working
on and it's funny based on the advice I
just Gap to Michael cuz it's really
grounded in something real to me the
mistake I made consistently for 20 plus
years was not delivering negative news
to people in my company when they were
underperforming cuz I didn't want to I I
viewed it as scaring them the lowest
point of my professional career was the
day I had the
AHA when I was 42 43 years years old
that I had spent 20 years trying to make
everyone feel safe but that I had built
enough of a reputation that people knew
they didn't fully know where they stood
with me because I could see OJ on Friday
be like O.J have the best weekend
brother love you keep up the good work
and on Monday call him in be like we're
going to have to let you go and he's
like yo what the [__] what happened on
Friday have the best weekend and I was
and what I did from 22 to 44 was I would
blame OJ in that scenario I'm like bro
he should have known like he knows he's
been and because I would sit on it
forever I he's been underperforming for
2 years I would I would put the blame on
him and the reality is my number one
favorite tradeit about myself normally
is full accountability I believe how
many people own their business raise
their hand let me give you one that is
just remarkable every single problem in
your company is 100% your
fault you hired the person you're
blaming and you can fire them and so
brother I'm so happy that I can talk in
public that I've gone from a 1 out of 10
on this issue to a
5.2 and boy has my company and my life
changed because of it and I'm excited to
hopefully get to a seven or eight I
don't think I'll ever get to 10 cuz DNA
is a powerful
[__] but but I could not deliver
negative feedback and I branded it in a
book and to my company now we call it
kind cander and I don't care enough
about money so I would carry people even
though I was losing profit
but I didn't realize I was actually
creating fear and that killed me like it
made me feel like my whole life's work
was broken so I've changed that and it's
been huge kind cander and I know a lot
of you who raised your hand struggle
with this especially because some people
are like your friend from high school
your cousin somebody that was with you
from day one but I'm telling you you
have to find kind
cander it also is a very good
relationship advice like it's real it's
real and it doesn't come natural to me
but it's real and that's the thing I
constantly made the same mistake on
thank thank you
[Applause]
brother you're good they going to turn
you on now got you what's up D nice to
meet you what's name Marco Marco yeah
nice to meet you so I like your jacket
bro thanks bro just got it
actually it's good so I own a company my
armn with my business partner Mike over
there uh we do canvis design branding
and packaging uh we've been doing for 2
years this is our actually second year
almost I think tomorrow is our her
second year anniversary which is awesome
it's
awesome employees you work with some of
the biggest brands in the country good
for you it's amazing U but the hardest
thing I've ever done with the most
rewarded makes sense right U my question
is not actually about my company I'm
very interested in artificial
intelligence in general and you actually
described artificial intelligence in an
interesting way before you described it
as a tool but the way I see it is
there's never been a tool in the history
of mankind time that was able to operate
itself and with open open AI you know
talking about autonomous agents coming
out next year yes you know potentially
in the next couple years 50% of maybe
white color jobs technically could be
done by AI you know and if that happens
what happens to our Workforce what
happens on a global a global standpoint
though what does it mean to what do you
think happened when the railroad was
invented 100% but my point is
intelligence has never been commoditized
thing the question will be I think it's
a you're you're barking up the right
tree you're right we've NE we've
attacked hard labor yes right we're now
attacking intelligence look I am not
putting like my entire life is based on
my perspectives and my ability look what
I look what we've been talking about my
whatever Knack I picked up with pattern
recognition DNA luck of the draw work
I've put in it's led me to be faster at
observing if I keep uploading questions
and thoughts into AI it will commoditize
me then you have to find a new non-c
commoditize thing this is the thing that
I'm optimistic about people I think
you're absolutely right we are about to
go into an era where things are about to
be commoditized that have historically
been the money maker right I mean one
could arue that beauty is going through
that
now you know like sure between filters
between plastic surgery between OIC like
you know like real talk like a
attractiveness is an advantage that
continues to get more and more
commoditized as the world has become
infatuated with everyone wanting to look
good so this happens all the time I
agree the size the scale the uniqueness
of something that has been trillions of
years in the making as value and the
speed in which we could see this we
could all wake up in six years and we're
there be there next year I I don't think
so and I think you'll learn that based
on what I just said about the metaverse
like it laws will come into like don't
underes estimate government corporations
humans fear that's what will catch you
on the one year the tech is there the
tech is there for us to all live 24/7 in
the metaverse so I don't think real life
will have it a year from today but to
your point yes can machines start to
think better than us we know that to be
true does that scare the [__] out of
people yes but I promise you if we were
lucky enough to all be able to go dig up
our great great grandmother and revive
her through new technology and she
opened up her eyes and calibrated the
world we live in for a day she'd be like
what the [__] is going
on you know the TV is a new invention
the TV the airplane is a fairly new
invention I'm fascinated by people's
inability to understand that Innovation
and Technology will always Advance like
literally there are 90-year-olds walking
around on Earth that remember life
forget about pre-
internet pre- telep but like real like
you know what I mean and so I what do I
think I think the human race has proven
for a very long time that will we we
will adjust and do I believe that many
people can be affected in the workforce
of course I do that's what always
happens the internet changed everything
and AI will do the same awesome thank
you so much cheers appreciate
[Applause]
it let me let me say something real
quick I want to get to the next question
real quick just to interlude everything
we've been talking about since this is
where the combo went the big takeaway
for all of you here is stop being a no
person and become a Maybe
person the fact that most people here
have not spent 10 hours 10 hours which
is a lot but a little in the scheme of
your life the fact that most people here
have not spent 10 hours researching
artificial intelligence is a
mistake it's a
mistake like forget about like you're
going to retire in 3 years like this is
going to impact your life if you plan on
living
this is real and like I don't understand
just saying no cuz one of your friends
said something or you read one headline
that like and you're you become all of a
sudden ideological about the workforce
but what really it is is you're hanging
on to that cuz you're scared because you
don't get it you're not good with
technology you need to spend the 10
hours to understand this because now
what will happen is you'll go from Full
defense to potential
offense promise your time when new
things pop off a couple of hours on
Googling you you know I have bad reading
comprehension go to YouTube It's a
second biggest search engine so you can
listen to it or watch it I didn't know
what the [__] nfts was you know 10 years
ago but I learned like and I I really
especially if you own it one more time I
apologize who owns a
business I don't
understand especially if you're looking
to not get completely taken out of
business in the next 5 years like
something could happen
I I spoke at the national this is insane
6 months after I or maybe a year after I
invested in Uber I was the keynote
speaker to the national black car and
texi Industry in Washington DC I was in
a room of like 5,000 taxi and black cab
owners and you can imagine the profile
of this
crowd and I said Uber and they laughed
so like we always think we have a moat
when we don't the only moat is leverage
with the
customer whoever is the closest and
provides the most value to a customer
wins so if some [__] Manan half ass
canvas or production facility builds a
very simple front-facing
website that uses AI correctly to allow
me to type in two sentences and
automatically render me at the lowest
cost a
booth even though you're in the physical
business I promise you that [__] is
going to be a problem for you you
understand that's how this world works
so I want to make sure everyone's locked
into this morning back to you know what
is it a Wednesday morning 11 you came
here for a reason I'm humbled by that I
want you to leave with action and real
different strategy and perspective and
so please pay attention to this
stuff my
man right here uh Gary my name is Shane
nice to meet you all thank you to
yourself and Phil Andro for you guys
hosting today uh so I'm in the gym
business I took over a small gym from a
mentor of mine a couple years ago my
first year out of college first year or
two was all like personal training and
like kind of working with athletes but
recently partnered with some good people
we're looking to make it like a 24/7
model self access Key Club and but we're
babies in the business industry we're
babies in content just starting to try
we got like 250 followers on Instagram
but zero better than zero exactly so
we're starting to grow it I would just
ask maybe what would be some advice you
have for someone who's just starting off
what are some things maybe you've seen
specific to the fitness industry that
have helped scale and then maybe just in
general eventually I'd like to kind of
grow my own kind of personal brand be
able to down the road step away from the
gym of throw online amazing everything I
just heard and as you can imagine the
the there may not be a more cliche
stereotype than the fitness dude who
built a Fitness business on social and
then decided to teach everybody how to
build business and build a personal
brand you're like in my pocket the
answer to the question is you need to
post 30 times a day on social media but
you have to be good at it so what you
need to do is what I just said about AI
you need to start googling and youtubing
and podcasting and educate yourself on
something I call sock strategic organic
content not just posting happy [__]
Wednesday and hoping it works like why
are you posting let me just pull it up
right now watch this it like this I'm
going into my phone I'm going into my
cont content team
WhatsApp and apologize I need to run to
a meeting so I'm going to run out pretty
quickly here so I apologize I'm going to
scroll up here it
is here we go this morning at 7:21 a.m.
McKenzie on my team said good morning I
need you to post at 5:04 p.m. and 7:07
p.m. on Instagram one needs to be a
carousel one needs to be a
real this is called the science but
behind the art I'm not out here posting
randomly for ha haa and my social media
strategy is not the
following all of yours
is I need you to understand the
thumbnail the first 3 seconds what time
you post how many words which platform
what's going on in LinkedIn carousels
that's different than Facebook carousels
Facebook what are broadcast channels do
you know what the [__] is going on this
is now the television and until you
understand that you are leaving money on
the
table back to scaring them this is how
it works brother right now everyone most
likely is just leaving double growth on
the table and then it becomes the thing
that puts them out of
business and so please take this serious
what you need to do how many times a day
do you post I know it's nothing how many
probably once a probably once one post a
day and some days not even right yeah
some days not even even better about one
a day and flooding stories and stuff
just Instagram think about where I am in
my career and where I want to go and
where you are you want to grow you're
your day one I shouldn't be the one in
this relationship posting 55 times a day
you understand yeah you will get
customers on LinkedIn you will get
customers on YouTube shorts you will get
customers on Snap Discovery you will get
customers on Pinterest and you're in the
best business you're in the visual
business take your shirt off and let's
go I got to go love
[Music]
you